last year Google engineer James damar
published a memo about workplace
diversity that led to his being fired by
the online giant the title of the ten
page document was Google's ideological
echo chamber and one of the reasons he
was let go was because he supposedly
perpetuated gender stereotypes in his
discussion but the memo didn't just
discuss gender issues it also raised
questions about Google's commitment to
ideological diversity earlier this year
the Lincoln Network a Bay Area group
that works to bolster libertarian and
conservative workers in the tech sector
published a survey on viewpoint
diversity and cultural norms in Silicon
Valley the results are preliminary but
stunning in the wake of the day more
memo for instance about half of
self-described moderates two-thirds of
libertarians and 71% of very
conservative respondents said they felt
less comfortable sharing ideological
viewpoints with their colleagues reason
sat down with Lincoln Network co-founder
Garrett Johnson to discuss his outfits
preliminary study why it's bad to stifle
ideological viewpoints in the tech world
and what it means that more survey
respondents called themselves
libertarian than any other term
what what's the nut of the of the study
I want to emphasize that it's a pilot
study we plan to do a much larger one
capturing more data the most important
component of this data is that it didn't
exist before we did it this is the first
of its kind there are lots of companies
that self-report data on ethnic
diversity gender diversity sexual
orientation but no one is capturing data
on viewpoint diversity right so
ideological diversity whatever he had in
the Bloodless you have about three
hundred and fifty six respondents most
men I think was like a t30 yeah so it
was three hundred eighty seven
respondents on the raw data
seventy percent technical 30 percent
non-technical about eighty percent men
twenty percent women across the
political spectrum a good distribution
between very liberal and very
conservative right and if I can just
jump in because this is reason I was I
was kind of surprised and heartened to
see that libertarian and these were
self-reported identifiers x' but
libertarian was the single largest yes
it was it was the single largest
identifier you know the the middle of
the moderate and liberal and being the
two largest so and I realized this was
self-reported but I'm the very liberal
what what kind of goes into that and
what goes into the very conservative do
you have a sense of if somebody says
they're very conservative what what do
they believe so in addition to capturing
that information we also captured
religious identity and so usually the
very conservative have a affinity to
some type of religious identity the
majority of people who competed the
survey the largest category was a
atheist and agnostic and that usually
skewed tourists are more very liberal or
liberal right
and now but you know part of this is
coming out after the James Day more memo
at Google talking kind of chiding his
comer his former employer for you know
caring about ethnic and gender diversity
and sexual orientation but not caring at
all about ideological diversity some of
the questions that you ask were things
like do you after the day more
kind of flap do you worry about talking
about politics in the workplace or have
you ever not talked about work politics
in the workplace what what were the
consistent findings that you you came up
with the consistent findings is that
that situation really put a chill on
conversations as it relates to you know
political ideology policy discussions in
the workplace so if you were very
conservative or conservative you were
above eighty percent less likely to
engage in these types of conversations
moderate 50% less likely if you even if
you were liberal you were about thirty
percent less likely to engage in these
types of conversations so the snapshot
that we got from post day more is that
the way Google handled that situation
cause people to become less open and
less willing to discuss discuss these
issues now in a one-way that's awful
because it's chilling of speech but in
another way is it maybe a good thing
that people aren't talking about
politics in the workplace it depends on
what type of ethos the company
encourages it you know Google places
like Salesforce they promote themselves
as being environments where they want
you to bring your whole self to work
they actively encourage it they invite
speakers to talk about policy or
politically oriented topics and so if if
that is going to be the ethos and the
culture that you create in the company
then you are doing a disservice to a
percentage perhaps a significant
percentage of your population who feel
that they cannot offer their perspective
in the workplace because they're going
to be shot it down
what happens Silicon Valley is
interesting where a lot of companies and
in the greater Bay Area part of their
brand part of their identity part of
their value proposition the customers is
that we're not just another company you
you can get tech you support from any
place but we are interested in helping
you know starving villagers in China or
we are committed to gender diversity
things like that is this you know it can
can you square the circle where is it
always going to be the fact that certain
companies are going to be like hey you
know what we
are very liberal or we're a very
conservative company and we don't you
know you don't fit in here so you
shouldn't work here I mean is there an
or resolvable tension in that so there
is this interesting narrative and
Silicon Valley that these companies are
saving the world even if it's you know
swipe left swipe right somehow they're
saving the world so there's a lot there
repopulating the world well there you go
that's that's important as well so
there's that that that narrative that
the industry tries to promote and they
have had a halo effect in many ways over
the years because there's this popular
sentiment this positive sentiment as it
relates to tech companies but that's
really shifting you're noticing that in
a number of ways before the narrative as
has always been big financial companies
or bit telco companies are harming
consumers they're doing bad things and
so they need to be punished they need to
be regulated but you know host 2016
election you know the role that the tech
companies may have played and in flaming
a divisive sort of tribal ization in our
country there's a growing sentiment that
these tech companies are harming
consumers they're doing bad things and
so we need to take a harder look at what
these tech companies are doing and to
what extent regulation is needed so
there's a there's a changing dynamic
with how the country sees places like
Silicon Valley so they're kind of
becoming the I mean now that uh you know
I don't know Lehman Brothers or
something doesn't exist or whatever Bear
Stearns is out of business
we need new villains and in the business
space and Google Facebook Twitter or or
might be filling that space they might
be you know it remains to be seen to
what extent this odd interest not only
from progressives but also from
conservatives turns into anything real
is there an tie trust is there new
regulation that remains to be seen but
there is skepticism about how much value
tech companies are actually bringing to
society are they harming democracy are
they enabling and helping democracy so
this was a pilot study was conducted
towards the end of last year with with
relatively few people when do you expect
to have a fuller kind of set of day
or findings short answers at the end of
2018 you know post the more when those
issues rise to the surface groups like
Lincoln Network because we're only game
in town we get inundated by journalists
who want to know you know are things
really as bad as everyone is saying
what's the ground-level truth and
unfortunately as I pointed out there was
no data and so we threw a study together
in a very you know short time frame just
to try to get a snapshot of what's
really happening capture some early data
so we plan to towards the end of this
year after the midterm election do a
larger survey survey trying to
understand how things gotten better have
things gotten worse we also focused
initial pilot only on Silicon Valley we
were you know got a lot of inbound
messaging from people and other tech
hubs who said they wanted to participate
but they didn't because it was focused
only on Silicon Valley so we want to
address a much larger part of the
country and as a final point can you
talk a little bit about Lincoln Network
and what you're trying to accomplish
with this group yeah so Lincoln network
is a national community of technology
professionals and we use our technical
skill sets to help advance economic and
individual liberty so that means
different things on the policy front we
try to help law makers at the local
state and federal level get up to speed
on emerging technologies so they're not
standing in the way of the future but
that they are creating policies enabling
a more prosperous future for everyone
and then on the technology side we
actually use our skill sets to help
government and civil professionals do
their jobs better so we've got you know
institutions that were created in the
19th century you know with regulations
that were created in the 20th century
trying to work within a world in the
21st century so there's a lot of
catching up that the government has to
do and we have technology professionals
who use their skills to help solve those
problems so we're trying to create a
freer and prosperous world by using our
skill sets I have you know I you know
take this for what it's worth but I hope
you let the government like don't let
the government catch up too much because
I think they only hope for freedom and
individual liberty is that we keep a
little bit ahead of them
think you may be right well I want to
thank you for talking we've been talking
with Garrett Johnson of Lincoln Network
they have a fantastic new survey about
political orientation and the way it
affects employment and kind of
water-cooler culture in Silicon Valley
Garrett thanks for talking thanks for
having me for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]